qu'en pense un de ceux qui est confronté
à cette réalité des restaurateurs danny
st pierre chef cuisinier et restaurateur
propriétaire bonsoir d'année bonsoir
monsieur roy alors est-ce que le modèle
doit changer parce que ce qu'on
comprenne est ce que c'est vrai qu'un
restaurant où ça coûte plus cher aux
drôlement moins les moyens de bien payer
des fouaces uc sont en cuisine qu'en
saint-hubert il ya beaucoup de facteurs
qui se met en place d'un le coût des
denrées quand on veut dans un restaurant
où ça coûte excessivement cher dans les
denrées sont coûteuses donc ça fait
monter le prix de la facture ça prend
beaucoup de manipulations aussi parce
que la cuisine d'auteur ou la cuisine
dite haut de gamme nappe blanche appelez
la comme vous voulez ça prend plusieurs
humains qui vont faire plusieurs petites
tâches spécifiques ce qu'il faut
comprendre aussi dans ces établissements
c'est qu'un facteur de risque pour
l'employeur quand on travaille les
denrées comme ça puis on accepte des
salaires qui sont un peu plus bas il ya
une partie de formation qui ce contenu
vous voyez sur le topo vous démontrer
ici le des petites manipulations tout
filmé il ya des gens qui vont se faire
la main l'attitude souvent à prendre des
gens qui vont à la sortie de l'école de
lits thq ou des écoles hôtelières dans
l'ensemble de la province leur formation
va se continuer donc le quiproquo qu'on
a vu avec monsieur picard qui proposait
un salaire de base qui était au salaire
minimum évidemment qu'on passait par des
pourboires ben vous pas ça s'appelle
commencé au bas de l'échelle j'écoutais
votre segment un petit peu plus tôt que
vous êtes fait normal danny st pierre
boudou c'est normal quelqu'un qui sort
de l'école les thq
commence au salaire minimum non c'est
pas nécessairement au salaire minimum il
faut choisir son type d'établissement
aussi il ya une grande différence entre
un saint-hubert et le pied de cochon et
nos motivations sont tout à fait
différentes d'aller travailler dans l'un
ou dans l'autre quand on parle du pied
de cochon mais le pied de cochon à mon
avis c'est une école c'est un porte
étendard de la cuisine culinaire la
cuisine on au québec on a eu un tony
bourdin qui est venu au québec à cause
de son en grande partie et qui a fait
rayonner notre province avec les
ce que ce que martin picard avait réussi
à démontrer donc moi je vous dis les
salaires sont augmentés parce qu'une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre puis une
certaine forme d'hypocrisie aussi parce
qu'à l'époque souvenons-nous le
peut-être 20 25 ans on parlait pas de la
cuisine on parle pas de la restauration
comme ça les salaires étaient déjà
beurre le prix de l'assiette était élevé
mais les marges étaient inexistantes
aussi plus ça va plus prix des denrées
augmente mais c'est difficile d'avoir
des gens on ne peut pas payer sa valeur
y a personne qui veuille aller mais
c'est vrai donc que la marge
bénéficiaire est si petit prenons pied
de cochon wire vous en avez eu 10
restera la wii points donc c'est vrai où
vous dit ça mais dans le fond
j'empochais plus là mais non on n'en
peut plus quand les denrées sont élevés
le souci c'est vous regardez un marché
comme new york ou paris où un las vegas
le premier lot un rite à peu près les
mêmes un peu partout c'est la capacité
de payer du marché qui va déterminer ce
qui va se passer dans l'assiette donc
dans les salaires le véritable problème
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de restaurants
ils se font compétition monsieur pajot
le disait professeur ali thq
précédemment les gens se font
compétition et n'ose pas augmenter les
prix parce qu'ils ont peur d'avoir une
salle à manger qui va être vide si tu
veux tu vas ont des clients dans ta
classe puis ton voisin vannes poitrine
de poulet 25 dollars tout l'avant 55
pour être capable de payer ton monde
comme il faut ce serait pas
concurrentielle tu y arriveras pas ok
bah c'est important vous êtes la seule
façon si on voulait augmenter
les salaires déjà cuits zen il faudrait
faire payer les plats beaucoup plus cher
ben il faudrait faire payer les plus un
peu plus cher mais il faudrait surtout
parler aux gestionnaires qui veut
engager les gens lorsqu'un service si
vous êtes en train de faire des soucis
de la pudeur du poulet des potes et des
sautés et des salades et des pokéball
elle se fait beaucoup d'humains
différents pour faire la même tâche si
vous avez une petite salle à manger puis
vous offrez tout ça vous dirait votre
masse salariale donc la tendance en ce
moment c'est de retirer des services
pour maintenir un prélat site qui va
être bon puis quand on parle de service
ou six mois je pense directement pour
bord qui sont en salle à manger qu'on
peut pas encore contrôlé parce qu'on
parle d'une infime partie de pourboire
qui peut être répartis dans l'ensemble
de la maison mais l'énorme travail
protège encore les salaires à pourvoir
dont les serveurs vont être payés 10 et
80 dollar qui en échange on les laisse
contrôler 15% du chiffre d'affaires de
la maison puis avec s'est délecté qui
fait donc le modèle je crois qui est là
à revoir aussi sur les menus on est
presque oui on voulait donner saint
pierre les beaucoup de propriétaires de
restaurants voulait qu'on qu'on
réglemente cette question du partage du
pouvoir ça passait pas passer non pour
vous c'est une des solutions je crois
que oui si vous savez c'est difficile on
parle de marge de profit de 5% donc il
faut que ça donne à quelque part comme
on dit en bon français something's gotta
give on parle de 5% de marge de profit
pso c'est quand on est chanceux puis on
ne peut pas vraiment des verts et qui
nous arrive puis quand on parle de ce
qui vient de se passer dans la nuit
dernière le bo de l'aide de tout le
monde est à sec tout le monde marche à
crédit ou à peu près il voir un gros
écrémage qui va se faire dans la scène
de la restauration donc je crois que ce
serait lors de ré ouvrir cette boîte de
pandore décès de répartir ce 15% leur
ensemble puis aussi quand on quand on va
au restaurant on est le prix qu'ils
étaient fichés mais évidemment les taxes
il pour voir ne sont pas dedans moi je
serais d'avis que d'inclure le pourboire
ça fait crier tout le monde parce qu'on
a l'impression d'avoir le contrôle sur
notre service qui on se dit ah ben si si
je peux pas décidément pour boire je
réponds à un bon service mais c'est là
que les maisons vont se démarquer et
c'est là qu'on va voir les
professionnels travaillent ici vous
allez pas vous acheter une auto à
un vendeur la commission en dix ans et
je vais y laisse un type qui va mieux me
vendre mon auto sur un meilleur service
c'est ça suffit la servilité un moment
donné on vous dit que des choses à faire
très concrète à ce que des restanques
peuvent plus ouvrir cinq six séjours
semaine y en a plein qui ferme le midi
ils n'y ont pas le problème du personnel
il est réel le problème du personnel il
est réel puis aussi la sécurité
l'investissement du restaurateur qui
vraiment pas considéré on peut dans la
plupart des villes au québec ouvrir un
restaurant ces normes d'urbanisme donc
si tu qualifies à être à 25 mètres d'un
autre établissement et puis de lanton
secteur tu peux être sur une rue
commerciale ou pas tu peux arriver
demain matin d'ouvrir un restaurant ce
qui arrive c'est qu'on est toujours dans
un effet de nouveauté et un restaurant
c'est un peu comme un film il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se font des lycées
il disait on va aller voir un nouveau
morceau à avaler si joe beef ont valu au
pied de cochon d'après ses crochets puis
ils vont pu je crois qu'on devrait
recommencer à adopter des restaurants et
quand on aime un endroit à leurs visités
mais je pense qu'il faudrait avoir le
courage politique aussi de faire on veut
arrêter de donner la permission aux gens
d'ouvrir des canaux où ils veulent en
venir pour vendre les fonds de commerce
serait que ça crée une valeur parce
qu'on peut pas la banque avec seul danny
st pierre on se reparlera de tout chasse
est une industrie importante merci
beaucoup merci monsieur roy au revoir à
la prévoir